David Boder: [In English] Paris, July 30th. July 30th, 1946. I am interviewing now a gentleman, a Polish refugee, Mr. Bolesław Czolopicki.
David Boder: [In Russian] Холост, сорока трех лет.
David Boder: [In English] Alright, er, you understand English?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: Yes. I understand a little.
David Boder: Now, I will ask you in English, if you would please answer in Polish. understand? You can answer in Polish, because we want to have it in the language you can best speak. You understand? Er...Where were you born, Mr. Czolopicki?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: In Poland?
David Boder: Yes.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: I must speak. In Poland?
David Boder: No, no, you speak Polish. Where were you born?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Urodziłem się w Warszawie.
David Boder: [In Russian] В Варшаве. Есть у Вас жена, дети?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Nie. Nie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы понимаете меня по-русски?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Rozumiem.
David Boder: [In Russian] Я буду говорить по-русски. Вы будете отвечать по-польски. Когда Вы уехали из России? Из Польши?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Było to po powstaniu w Warszawie w roku czterdziestym-czwartym
David Boder: [In Russian] О, в тридцать четвертом году? Куда Вы поехали?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Byłem deportowany przez Niemców.
David Boder: [In Russian] В тридцать четвертом?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Nie w czterdziestym-trzecim. W czterdzieści-czwartym.
David Boder: [In Russian] А, в сорок четвертом Вы выбрались из Варшавы? Почему Вы уехали из Варшавы?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] No, Niemcy wszystkich deportowali z Warszawy.
David Boder: [In Russian] И куда Вас депортировали,
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Deportowali do Nadrenii.
David Boder: [In Russian] Хорошо. Теперь Вы мне расскажите по-польски все, что с Вами было с того момента, как немцы взяли Варшаву, и до того дня, как Вас освободили в Париже. Идите—говорите. .И не сокращайте, во всех деталях.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Z chwilą kiedy piatego pażdrziernika czterdziestego-czwartego roku Niemcy całą ludność Warszawy...er...deportowali...do Niemiec. Jest dla mnie troche trudno...
David Boder: Po Polsku powiedzić?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: Nie. Tylko wogóle taką forme ująć . .
David Boder: [In Russian] Говорите как хотите. Говорите, как Вы будете говорить с кем-нибудь другим. Вы сейчас разговариваете. Это все.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish]...Więc...odesłano nas, znaczy dano nam możność...er...spakowania rzeczy swoich, tyle tylko to co no siębie można było...er...pieszą przejść do Ursusa,znaczy miejsca pare kilometrów odalonego od Warszawy. Tam nas trzymano koło dwóch dni I następnie w pociągach towarowych...er...z eskortą oczywiście...Niemiecką. Wieziono nas przez blisko pieć dni i nocy w gląb Niemiec do Nadrenii.
David Boder: [In English] And then?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish]...Oczywiście ludzie byłi mięszani- znaczy kobiety, dzieci, męszczyzni, wszyscy rażem. Warunki były okropne dlatego ze wogóle, powięcmy, w wagonach towarowych nie było...odpowiednych wygód...czasami przystawali źeby moźna było zrobic toalete. Oczywiście wszystko to pod straża, wspólnie rażem męszczyzni i kobietami, bo inaczej nie moźna było. . . No, wyźywienie Oczywiście było też bardzo kiepskie, raż jesc na dzien. . . Kiedy znależmyśmy się juz na [Wanne?] kolo Bochum wtedy przyjechaliśmy akurat na moment kiedy Bochum było bombardowane przez...Anglików. Nalotu tego był wynik taki ze pięć wagonów zostało spalonych, kilka osob też spalonych, zabitych.....Reszta nas została odwieziona do obózu, do obózu rozdzielczego...pod Wessen. Tam trzymano nas też w warunkach Oczywiście bardzo primitywnych, [niezrozumiały] w podłodze, scisku, jeden na drugim, nie mial swoje posłanie. Trzymano nas...zdajesię mieśiąc czy dwa mieśiąca. Potem rodzielano Oczywiście do róźnych fabryk albo też na liscie do pracy na wsi. Ja dostałem się do. . . pod Geldern-Kapellen gdzie...byłem zatrudniony przy obózie ktory był —znajdowlisię deportowani, I przy pracy, przy kopaniu okopu...Tam spędziłem. . . pozostałem, czas aż do....uwolnienia przez Amerykan. 3 marca...1945 zostałismy uwolnieni przez Amerikan...No i wowczas deportacja Niemiecka się skonczyla. Czy mam jeszcze mowic dalsze...?
David Boder: [In Russian] Tak, tak. Так, так.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish]...Nastepnie z Amerykanami...napisalem się do Amerikan tam do pracy i z Amerykanami przyjechalem do Francji. Jakis czas pracowalem we Francji z Amerikanami. Nastepnie zwolnilem się , przyjechalem do Paryza gdzie rozpoczelem dalsze studia w szkole desen.
David Boder: [In Russian] Скажите мне вот что. Вы все время работали в концентрационном лагере?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Nie to nie był właściwie konzentracyjny obóz tylko obóz deportowanych do—właściwie do pracy.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага! Вы работали, а как они вас кормили?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Wyźywienie było oczywiście...brukiew, było [szumy tła; niezrozumiały] wyźywienie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага! Кто были вашими начальниками—немцы или они имели поляков? Nie. Więc Niemcy. Ci ze słuźby w tych źółtych mundurach. To było Ich—nie pamietam jak to się nażywalo—partynicy z Volkspartii Niemieckiej.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага, ага.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] W źółtych mundurach z takimi opaskami.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага, ага, СС свастика.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Zdajesię ze to było [szumy tła; niezrozumiały]. . . co jeszcze potrwa.
David Boder: [In Russian] А где Вас американцы освободили? В каком городе?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] [niezrozumiały] Moers.
David Boder: [In Russian] в Мерс...над Рейн?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: Tak.
David Boder: Ага. Вы что—собираетесь вернуться в Польшу?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Narażie mialem zamiar konczyc tutaj studia [inaudible] Co jeszcze potrwa.
David Boder: [In Russian] А что Вы учитесь теперь?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Teraż ucze się wlasnie radia.
David Boder: [In Russian] Радио. Вы платите что-нибудь в этой школе?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Do tej pory w tamtej szkole place.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы платите?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Ale tutaj mam byc oplacany. W tej szkole...
David Boder: [In Russian] А Вы учитесь тут днем? Вы работаете в Париже?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Nie. Znaczy do tej pory pracowalem , teraż ponieważ zapisalem się na ten kurs więc przestalem pracowac. No it tutaj ma byc ten kurs platny.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага, а где Вы живете в Париже?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Ja na Le Bonoir [?]
David Boder: [In Russian] Частным образом? Много там поляков вместе живете?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Nie, ja mieszkam w hotelu.
David Boder: [In Russian] Есть у Вас родственники в Америке? Есть ли у Вас родные в Америке?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Nie. Nie posiadam zadnych krewnych w Ameryce.
David Boder: [In Russian] Нет родственников в Америке. А что Вы собираетесь: остаться во Франции или что Вы собираетесь делать?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Ja chcialbym najchetnie emigrowac.
David Boder: [In Russian] Куда?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Powięcmy wlasznie do Ameryki.
David Boder: [In Russian] В Америку?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Jezeli by była mozliwosc.
David Boder: [In Russian] А скажите, когда Вы были в Варшаве, до сорок четвертого года, Вы были там, когда был этот погром в гетто?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Owszem. Byłem. Caly czas byłem aż do czterdziestego-czwartego roku. Byłem w Warszawie przez caly okres wojny. Oczywiście też musialem się przed Niemcami stale ukrywac.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Nawet...pod cudzym nażwiskiem. W czasię tego Pogromu...w Warszawie byłem I...ciagle walke getta Oczywiście z daleka obserwowalem I widzialem.
David Boder: [In Russian] А...Вы думаете, что Вам удастся поехать в Америку—без рожственников? Хотели бы Вы поехать в South, в Южную Америку?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Brażilia.
David Boder: [In Russian] Бразилия. Вы говорите по-французски хорошо?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Troszke. Znaczy rozumiem.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Moge czytac. . .
David Boder: [In Russian] Можете читать?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] pisze dosc dobrze,
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага.
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] tylko rozmowa, jesli chodzi o rozmawianie jeszcze pewne trudnosci mi to sprawia...[szumy tła]. bardzo szybko.
David Boder: [In Russian] Спасибо, господин Хлопицки. Это было очень интересно—то, что Вы мне рассказали. Я хочу один маленький эксперимент...У меня тут имеются кое-какие картины. Что Вы думаете, что эта картина представляет?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Jest to fotografia kobiety. [szumy tła]
David Boder: [In Russian] Говорите громко. Да, и что это представляет собой?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish]...chlopca, zamyslonego, siędzacego na [szumy tła; niezrozumiały]
David Boder: [In Russian] Хорошо. Что эта картина собой представляет?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] [pauza] A to przedstawia...osobe chora, umarla, czy zmarla, a nad nia stoi...
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага. А что тут происходит?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] Wyglada tak jak przed jakims nalotem uciekaly kobiety.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага. А эта?
Boleslaw Czolopicki: [In Polish] [szumy tła] To praca na wsi. Z jednej strony...praca przy ogrodce ziemi, mycie oraż [szumy tła; niezrozumiały]...z drugiej strony jakis ten goral nauczy z ksiaszka w reku. Kobieta...[niezrozumiały]
David Boder: [In English] Alright...